الاعلانات خلينا نتكلم عنها اللي اللي
دائما تطلع وتظهر للاشخاص الذين يتناولون
الوجبات السريعه يمكن في الواقع ان تدفع
اولئك الذين يتبعون نظاما غذائيا لا تناول
كميات اقل وطبعا هذا الكلام بحسب دراسه
جديده مشاهدينا نشرت في مجله
وجدت ان مجرد رؤيه شخص ياخذ ياكل الوجبات
السريعه يكفي لابعاد متابعي الحميات عنها
يا ريت لان هذه الصوره الذهنيه بما في ذلك
استهلاك الطعام يمكن تنشيط شبكات عصبيه
مماثله لتلك المرتبطه بالاداء او التجربه
الفعليه يعني شبع
نحن كانه هو اللي اكل فصور مشاهدينا
الاستهلاك قد تجعل الناس يتذكرون خطا انهم
اكلوا الطعام المعروض ومجرد التفكير في
اننا تناولنا شيئا ما يمكن ان يجعلنا نشعر
بالشبع فعلا الدراسه اثبتت ان الاطلاع
المستمر ودائما المكثف على صور الاطعمه
اللذيذه في انستجرام كفيل بان يكبح شهيتك
بشكل ملحوظ وذلك الاكتفائك النفسي برؤيه
هذه الاطعمه بشكل متكرر مو يقولون العين
تاكل العين تاكل فعلا عين تاكل هلا انا ان
شاء اليوم راح اتغدى على صور انستغرام
وين وين ريحه ريحه السمك
وبتحسسك كانه اكلت انت كمان
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات